[Music]
um
there's a question play levy rosman
question mark
i played levy hundreds of games online
you can search youtube for
our various matches
[Music]
okay fine i'll open just.com
but levy house to start the game or make
a challenge if he really wants to play
[Music]
how do i see who's challenging me
no we're playing okay i knew he had the
power to start a game
though his ra he's yeah he retired from
chess and then
like gained a ton of rating and now he's
200 points higher than me is this rated
no it's unrated i wanted to farm him
okay
are we playing increment or no no
increment okay
okay it's time
to play levy
um
i'll play this uh funny thing
f3
e92
[Music]
i score 35 against it frown
against english
oh yeah i could but um
actually i have a video on my youtube
channel it's an old video
but it's called lesson with tam english
opening or something
and uh
i show a tricky
approach
my bishop should be on g5
i don't know why i did that
uh
okay
yeah i shouldn't be trading verse 4
bishops when there's a pawn in e5
okay so i want to play this move
bishop f2
[Music]
i'm a little bit underdeveloped that's a
great move queen b4 maybe queen d3
and this bishop found a
nice home
i was trying to play the cool pierce
line that i was showing earlier
but it didn't really work so much in my
favor
so f5 is coming
i think i just have to roll with the
punches
should be two
and like queen d1
wow he's being aggressive
i'm somehow holding on
trade with me
i want to play queen d3
takes takes bishop d7 d4
it looks questionable
[Music]
wow
[Music]
i want to make d4 work
yeah if take six ticks i take on b7
i mean got my heart rate monitor going
it feels like my heart rate is
increasing currently
takes and
i wanted to take
king of one
i wasn't sure what to do there
a 92
[Music]
b3
um
i feel stuck
in this move
weird move but
i want to do this
i'm in trouble
how do i not lose
what happened to my time
and all my hope oh no my king
well played
yeah i got under pressure later in the
game there
oh i'll play my fun rapper tour against
english who is asking
is craig craig a okay
this is what i show in this old video
[Music]
on youtube
uh it's a reverse grand prix attack
and
it requires a slightly different player
than usual grand prix
but it's same kind of attacking
principles
okay king h8
bishop here
um
i wonder if i can like move the knight
there's some weird ideas here
because of knights are superfluous i
want to play this and then retreat again
and then play c6
and then redevelop
yeah it might make sense to
to play c5 now
[Music]
close things down a little bit
we trade in night of seven
interesting
i wonder if i can take
and the bishop bishop's going to be
strong but
the knight can hop around
i want to play knight f6 a lot of night
maneuvering do my thing
rooks are only good if there are open
files though
so i don't mind this
oh that's a good move though
or is it
that's a good move
uh takes takes
and knight h6
i know sometimes levy gets nervous in
these things
wait what is this prediction
the winner of the game or winner of the
match
oh but probably the winner of the mat of
the game
i got the focus here
um
even though it's really bad at this
point
takes takes
maybe i can take and pawn takes i take
on c4
rook takes there's knight f5
the light wants to travel to d4
this horsey wants to turn into a giga
horsey
okay gigahorsey achieved
but does it do anything
d5 ideas
g5 ideas
let's slow play a little bit
i'm just more comfortable being down
material against levy for some reason
how to do this
take take
gigger horsey beat the batman's please
oh no my queen i didn't even have time
to say oh no my queen
oh it's a funny stalemate i wasn't
expecting levy to fall for that i would
understand if levi wants to rage quit
right now how do i see levy's reaction
levy where's my levy
that's
i don't know how the i don't know how oh
sorry for the language
looks like he's handling it okay though
okay uh i'll play e4
oh i forgot i i um
yeah this is my prep
let me see if i remember my prep
bishop h5
bishop e2
it's been a while since i looked at this
i prepared this for uh jovi
ivanka houska
but it's been a while
i should really play this and understand
the plants for white
uh
okay so that's why a6 was played
am i already worse here
maybe it's not so bad
in that a4 ideas
that's an interesting type of structure
allowing another five um
it's still interesting though
i like this uh i have another gig of
horsey on b6
if he doesn't take i'm ready to
reinforce
there's also lingering potential of
knight d7
like if queen f6 knight d7 is a
quadruple fork
wow
what is this position
[Music]
yeah rook f7 is a good move
this probably makes sense b4 is a type
of move i end up playing
eventually i'm not sure if my rook wants
to stay on f1
maybe this move
idea b5 remove the knight win the pawn
and this might just kind of stuck i mean
it could move back to g7
wow
okay so i'm keeping the rook defending
the pawn
bishop will find a new home
b5
i think i'm winning the pawn or the
knight
yeah because now there's two attackers
and queen d2 will probably be played
so like 97 takes queen d2 queen e3 looks
solid
[Music]
i should win oh e6 isn't hanging in that
line
uh
up a lot of time though
eu6 is tender
hmm
i guess i'll play bishop b1 kind of a
sad move but now g6 is also tender
oh i blundered
or did i
funny line
stop it
there we go okay
got the ladder meet levy's fast
i i had enough time there
knight f3
ah
playing b3 i prepared this for him in
our match
but what did i prepare
did i prepare this
now i'm just forgetting
i'll just play a reverse london
looks reasonable
[Music]
now yeah this move
i sometimes play this as white i mean as
black i'm kind of down a tempo
but maybe it's okay
uh
interesting play this move
trying to understand what's going on
here
i think it's okay to give away a dark
spot bishop
because i can get a structure where most
my pawns are on dark squares
ideally i should have my pawn on f6
take with this knight probably put this
knight back and then f6
yeah it's some kind of marathi bind
structure
the problem is if i play f6 too soon
there's f4
and bishop could be undefended
yeah this looks to be okay
i'm an id4 idea
are there takes in queen f3 wow
i have queen g7
[Music]
like everything's defended
and you just gave away like a important
bishop too
uh oh
die blunder
i have to be really careful here i want
to take with pawn but knight of fix
i take with other pawn
[Music]
which may be okay
yeah positions a little bit delicate
should probably play half six at some
point
like move the bishop
i want to transfer over to the c file
uh yeah knight's rerouting
put the bishop on d5
threatening this now
maybe even this
and also this plan
[Music]
he really wants to play f4
oh my rook is trapped or is it
this move and then this move
was it close
it's going to be a time scramble
wow he has a night piece
this move first
draw
no draw
i'm down in time though
i can probably end up forcing a draw if
i want
i should probably play for a win
yeah there's some back rank issues for
whites
oh for me too
there we go
i've had similar cases in puzzle rush
where the the king is sheltered from the
rook
checks okay gg
uh what else can i play against carol
khan
oh he wants to play the schliemann let's
play ponziani
yeah i know schliemann uh is one of his
pet lines
he played against nemo
yeah if only this were raided
[Music]
my rating has taken a dip recently
is he gonna play bishop c5
yeah oh this is a funny line
so i have to take
and then the key is to take in bishop b6
and queen d5
yeah this got super super sharp
oh neil was asking about ponziani
earlier in the chat
wait b takes
i thought there's a reason why this
isn't common
i have knight d2
92 bishop a6 c4
and this is one of like the more
critical lines in ponziani
it gets super super sharp it's risky for
both players
black stacked a piece but i've
been forced against my will to bond
cloud
yeah if i didn't have c4 then i was
almost getting mated but thankfully
thankfully there's no pawn to ambassador
me um on poisson meet me
um okay so i could take the bishop or
the knight
probably the bishop
and if takes i can play queen e2
[Music]
or maybe queen a4
okay for certain does that i did not see
that move
the king e1
or king g1
king g1 i guess
put the bishop on e3
e5 is still attacked
i want to play c5
sneakily hitting the knight
blocking the bishop too
[Music]
i should change the stream title
playing levy
okay
title updated
rook improved
okay
it's a nice positional pawn
i mean all pawns are
positional in some sense but this pawn
is extra positional
develop the bishop allowing this
oh but then i take
play this move
rook b8
i'm taking c6
and just try and confuse him a little
bit
because the knight can't be taken
be a b3
okay now he does want to take
or does he takes takes rook h3
confusing position
[Music]
hmm
oh my thing is pinned
oops
oh no
[Music]
how about is this
oh the final position is winning too i
just didn't have enough time
oh
it's a little bit too slow there
good game though
okay
we're repeating some lines that we had
in our match
although i don't think we played into
this
this early a6 line
hey
it's open mind simon appreciate the raid
yeah i really appreciate it if you're
just joining i'm playing a match against
gotham chess
and we're having some fun games
trying to figure out what to do in this
position
actually not sure what to do
[Music]
could play
like b5
maybe b5
i mean he wants to play e4 though
and bishop d6
okay i'll try bishop d6
it's a risky move because i'm allowing
e4 but maybe it's not so bad
because i can take
and then move back
oh
oh he's so clever
[Music]
or is he
yeah it's kind of clever
this could get really bad really quickly
young children close your eyes
so after it takes takes
takes takes
check knight f8
i am threatening bishop e6 there
oh fancy
i play bishop e6 first
lose a couple pawns
i can't take it i have to
pray that this works
and it probably doesn't work but let's
try it
yeah this does not work at all
[Music]
but maybe it will confuse them enough to
get me
less down on time
oh thank you cmy gz something something
ah well played
king hh
oh king aj rook takes while
i have to play this
i mean everything's losing though
uh
for this move
i have no time man
not thrilled with the position
[Music]
my only hopes does a stalemate trick
uh let's play
play this move first
no
oh i want to try this still me trick
okay we'll go back to e4 how about
i'll play d3
d3 knight d2 how about i'm curious what
he does against this he's probably gonna
play g6
or this line
i wonder if he prepared this for me
this is a old opening prep
97
there's some gambit where i play e5 i
think i can castle first
yeah levy's fast
so if takes there's queenie one key move
unpinning and then regaining the pawn
yeah my prep is like gradually coming
back to me
even though i'm probably already out of
prep
we have a totem pole d file
[Music]
probably want to play c3
c3 bishop d2
looks like a solid move
and develop
trying to develop naturally
i'm also just trying to stay up on time
too
oh
can we trade
yeah box in the position where the
bishop has a hard time developing like
takes takes i'm controlling
the light squares
we might see bishop d7
yeah bishop d7
can i exploit anything here
another five maybe
like maybe i'll get a slightly favorable
bishop versus knight
end game
oh he offered a draw
doesn't that signify fear
i thought generally like these endings
are slightly preferable for the bishop
i could be wrong though
c4 maybe
to be careful putting the pawns on light
squares though
because the pawns should complement the
bishop
and not disrespect the bishop
a4
okay he's setting up this
cheesy fork
this move looks nice
not here ooh
it almost looks wrong
like this
do what did i do
i got forked
it's still interesting though
it's actually still interesting
oh it's still bad for me though
or is it
what are my chances to not lose this
oh i feel so broken
can i dirty flag him
no he has so much time oh it's so sad
uh
yeah all i had to do was not get forked
ah what to do
okay i'll play the english line again
uh yeah he wants to play d4
i prepared this for him in our match
i'm trying to remember what i prepared
though
i think i prepared e4
i'm okay going into this
and takes and
[Music]
f6
bishop b4
yeah we played some game in uh new york
that featured some kind of position like
this
fight c3 actually is probably
a good move
did you ever wake up in the morning and
think you were meant to do something
extraordinary
uh sometimes
like today i woke up and then
then the extraordinary thing i proceeded
to do
was
snooze my alexa
and then even more extraordinary
i went to brush my teeth
every day starts in some extraordinary
fashion
eventually i want to trade and then
trade some more and then use a b file
is e4 coming
wow
i should probably take not pretty
white's got the bishops
but i got
i got a knight
i'll probably end up playing f6
i maneuver the knight
i mean
e5 might come eventually
so i want to be prepared for it
but he's also preparing for it
does it work e5
takes e6
wow it might actually work
let's go
world in less than 4 vs 3k bits
oh
i'm a little bit preoccupied now but
later i'll
be less preoccupied
or just less occupied
maybe it's not so bad
[Music]
or is it so bad
yeah i should have i should have had
more danger levels
takes takes
okay let's survive
how to survive down material
this is maybe not even so bad like
rookie seven the light squares are weak
bishop's undermined by my
giga pawns
i have this and this
doesn't quite work
uh maybe this move
i didn't want to trade queens but what
else to do
[Music]
oh bishop a5 could hurt me
rook c8
takes takes
really
queen h6 here
i just want to go for meat
and he also wants to go for meat
am i getting mated queen e6 king h8
it's close
but it's also close for me
meeting i'm also attacking a bishop
allight swords are very very vulnerable
yeah plenty of time okay
man he like he squeezed me and then he
won material and then somehow i counter
punched
very tricky game
eric feel free to respond whenever you
are not focusing but what are your
thoughts on making multiple premoves
like in chess.com what would you think
if they added that feature to leech s2
um yeah it's a different feel i don't
think it makes a huge difference
i'm also trying to remember my theory
here
i think i'm supposed to just defend
i play the similar line as uh
[Music]
bishop g4
i've definitely played a similar line as
black in the past
oh there's c5 c5 a move
takes takes
it's interesting
there's one way to try and undermine
black's pawns
yeah i think the the bigger difference
because there's two main differences
between leachates and chess.com when it
comes to
like time scrambles and especially in
bullet
is the multi-pre moves but then also
like pre-moves still take 0.1 seconds on
chasse.com
and it may not seem so significant but
it makes a big difference in
time scrambles because on leachates you
can play
you can play infinite moves with one
second left but shots.com you can only
play a few before you flag
yeah i think in general i feel a little
bit more comfortable on the chest
but that might be because like it's
it's a bit smoother like the the pieces
move a bit more hey eric who is your
favorite supporter or all time when it
comes to twitch
oh
haha
what was that guy's name
what was the um
[Music]
i mean i can't pick favorites
first of all
i
think should just be grateful for all
the supporters
but there's definitely some some ogs
and
uh yeah there's a lot of there's been a
lot of supporters over time
the
um
i i can't even give an answer to that
because there's been so many if i even
if i mention
like one then
i feel bad not mentioning everyone else
but i do appreciate your support
dirty harvard and also half loaf thank
you half love
gifting five
what is a6
a6 seemed like such a random move
i guess it makes some sense in this
position
[Music]
play knight t5 here
95
interesting
i'm threatening to take a knight in
bishop b6
queen a5 i
think i might is b4 working
i don't think b4 is working
[Music]
yeah the king of two is my original
thought
a lovey is really down on time
i wonder if he's also getting distracted
by
generous support in his chat
wait did i just trap the queen
my intention was knight c7 and fork but
the queen
is
it's almost trapped
i mean it's simpler just to do this and
this
yeah like on leachates i think that this
would be a maybe closer time scramble
but here it should be like easier to
flag
easier to go for the flag and it's also
just winning too
okay
uh we're tied four and a half four and a
half
okay i'll play
i'll play back to my roots
i had a line in this uh earlier
i think takes an e5
was it yesterday yesterday's title
tuesday i was trying to
improvise oh levy's dog was bar oh shout
out to benji
i saw benji recently
benji loves me so much
i think h5
a4 is sometimes played with intention of
bishop a3
but uh a4 is also weakening to b4
f3 wow so if i take take take queen c8
interesting interesting
if knight a6 takes knight before queen
b1
hmm
let's go for this i'll suck upon
hmm
spicy move
yeah i lost the key center con and now
things are kind of sad
the only reason i came to this channel
was because was up in the air with you
and the pilot got sick you took over the
plane and
i really don't know how to show my
gratitude uh you're welcome
i know that that's nothing to sneeze at
but um
anytime
i play this move
wait what happened to my time
okay let's castle and then i have to go
all out to
try not to lose
i'm controlling b1
and things are getting messy here and
this is what i want
wow
thanks again eric yoga you're the hero
we all need not the one we deserve my
pleasure
but can i be heroic in this position
the game is really turned around
d2
almost works
c5 may be coming c5 i take it
i want to play this and this
oh he's such a kind person
not going for the flag
ah what a wholesome finish to such a
dirty game
that was a funny game though
what a game
[Music]
should we call it a draw
i s i told levy before we even started
playing i i told him no more than 10. so
he played 10 games
yeah chess is a draw
hence uh the draw finish and the five to
five
were just equal strength
even though he's over 200 points higher
rated than me now okay that was nice
ending ah it could have been nicer if we
played one more move
uh if you're watching in the future on
youtube i might put this whole match on
youtube
because i think it made for pretty good
youtube content
have a fun stalemate trick
had some fun openings
anyway yeah this this stream started
with like a chill q a
and now we're here
calming down after a somewhat wild match
[Music]